biden a déclaré qu'il voulait fermer
guantanamo, mais jusqu'à présent, nous avons vu
des signaux très mitigés de la part de son administration à
ce sujet, la poursuite des opérations de
guantanamo reste une tache
sur notre politique et sa réputation
dans le monde
[Musique]
[  Musique]
il y a 39 personnes à guantanamo il
y en a encore 780 au début
seulement 12 d'entre elles ont été
accusées d'être liées au
terrorisme extraordinairement
presque toutes ont été torturées ce
ne sont pas seulement les personnes accusées de terrorisme
qui ont été torturées presque toutes l'
ont été  torturés, nous sommes toujours là
parce que ce lieu de haine, de
violence et de
punition a survécu, a survécu à deux
décennies, a survécu à quatre présidents et
a résisté à toutes nos protestations,
chants, jeûnes et travail,
mais nous sommes toujours là
[Musique]
alors
vous